the ultimate goal of growing roses is to
make other people happy we believe we
give them the best that we can I am
responsible for six hundred and thirty
thousand process I love the roses
[Music]
Lake Naivasha Kenya could also be called
Rose heaven the climate and freshwater
supply have allowed many to farm some of
the world's most coveted flowers the
growers here work extra hard to make
sure that the Roses that end up in
bouquets all around the world look
perfect my name is Whitney got an engine
gas
my main job here is to take care of the
roses we harvest between three hundred
thousand in a day to 450 depending on
the web we have various colors
we have pink we have oil yellow Red's a
good Rose is a perfect one which is free
of any diseases or any pests and is of
good length and good stem weeds we have
some secrets to growing the Rose as well
but we can share them whilst many would
be surprised to learn that Kenya is a
center for these flowers Rose production
has flourished in the region over the
last few decades from planting to the
time of harvest it takes twelve weeks we
harvest when the flower buds are showing
the right color and then the length of
the Rose is also a determining factor
and the shape of the rose whinnies
perfect roses are then shipped off to
Europe Japan and the US and many other
worldwide destinations and then when he
heads back to work to create more
beautiful bouquets the love for roses
gives you the desire to learn more we
are really appreciate and feel fulfilled
to see other people happy at what we
produce it's like we embrace our daily
job
[Music]
you